في الجلسه ذاتها قال الرئيس البولندي
اندريد وان احد لم يكن دوده لم يكن يتخيل
ان تقوم روسيا بغزو اوكرانيا كما لم يكن
احد يتخيل مدى صمود اوكرانيا اشاره دوده
الى ان الاوروبيين لم يقوموا لم لم يقولوا
ان اوكرانيا ستكسب الحرب لكنها لن تخسر
على احد تعبان
دوده عسكري الحديث والمتطور سيمكن
اوكرانيا من الانتصار في الحرب عوده
الرئيس الهولندي اعلنت مؤخرا تقديمها
اربعه 10 دبابه متطوره الى اوكرانيا
عن اعتقاده بان اوكرانيا يمكن ان تكون
عضوا في الناتو خلال الاعوام قليله لكنه
اعرب عن خشيته مما سمعها حاله الياس التي
اصابه الرئيس الروسيه
مشددا على ان فوتن عليه ان يدرك انه اخطا
في حساباته
ينضم الينا من مقر منتدى مراسل الجزيره
عبد الله الشامي عبد الله من الواضح بان
روسيا هي الحاضر الغائب في هذا المنتدى
في اوكرانيا هي محور الاحاديث هنا حتى وان
كما ذكرت لم تكن حاضره باي تمثيل للسنه
الثانيه على التوالي لكن بالطبع الحديث عن
اوكرانيا هو ما سيسيطر على المشهد خلال
جلسات هذا المنتدى التي تستمر حتى الجمعه
اليوم
بالاضافه الى هذه الجلسه التي تحدثت
معناها سيكون هناك ايضا كلمه خاصه لكل من
الرئيس الاوكراني وزوجته ثم سيكون هناك
ايضا جلسه اخرى تتحدث عن امكانيه او مخاطر
استخدام السلاح النووي كذلك في اوكرانيا
بلا شك ايضا خلال الايام المقبله اوكرانيا
ستكون حاضر لكن اليوم ربما هذه التصريحات
لجيران قريبين لترك اه لاوكرانيا عفوا
بولندا همم يعني تحدث عما قالوا انها حاله
من ربما الخوف من ان الوحده التي ظهرت بين
الاوروبيين خلال هذه الحرب في اتخاذ
المواقف لا زالت ربما غير قادره على توحيد
المواقف بشان ارسال الاسلحه التي يطلبها
اوكراني حديث هنا بالتحديد ما كثر الكلام
عنه في الفتره الماضيه الدبابات الالمانيه
المتطوره التي تريدها اوكرانيا رئيس
البولندي الذي كان يزور كييف الاسبوع
الماضي قبل هذا المنتدى قال انزلينسكي
صراحه رئيس الاوكراني تحدث معه عن مدى
الحاح ارسال هذه الدبابات نعلم ان المتشرع
الماني له كلمه في الغد ايضا هنا صباح
الغد هنا في منتدى دافوس وربما سيكون بلا
شك هذا الامر ضمن محاور حديثه لكن ارسال
الدعم العسكري المتطور الى اوكرانيا كان
حديث هذه الجلسه لكن ربما تمت اشارات ايضا
الى مخاوف من التاثيرات التي فيما بعد
الحرب تحدث عنها الرئيس التواني تحدث عنها
الرئيس المقدوني حول ان الوحده الظاهره
حاليا اذا لم يتم البناء عليها مستقبلا
ربما نفسهم مره اخرى بعد انتهاء الحرب
التي قال عنها او قال عنها الجميع بلا
استثناء انهم لم يكونوا يتوقعون ان تصل
الى عام وهناك ربما حاله احباط او حاله من
عدم اليقين بامك انتهائها قريبا لكن تمت
اشارات تاكيدات على ان العلاقه بين
الطرفين للولايات المتحده الاوروبيين
اصبحت اقوى مما مضى بسبب الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن همم اعاده تاكيد من جانب
وزير الخارجيه الاسباني الذي ايضا شارك في
هذه الجلسه على ان الحرب ليست حرب
الاوروبيين ولا حرب النيترو لكن الدعم
العسكري هو بسبب ما قامت به روسيا لكن
الجميع اتفق بلا شك او انتهت الجلسه الى
ان المخاوف فعليا مما اسماؤه عدم منطقيه
القرارات او الخطوات اللي اتخذها الرئيس
الروسي وان هذا ربما يمكن ان يؤدي الى ان
تنتهي حرب فعلا لكن بشكل لا يريد احد ربما
بعمل عسكري ضخمه ربما ب- المخاوف او الخوف
الاكبر استخدام سلاح النووي من قبل موسكو
شكرا لك عبد الله الشامي مراسل الجزيره
كنت معنا من دابوس